klimakleber Leim Luschen Uhu Ultras die
Liste der Spitznamen für die radikalen
klimaaktivisten wird immer länger sie
terrorisieren mittlerweile ganze
Innenstädte sorgen für Staus Wut in der
Bevölkerung und attackieren sogar
wertvollste Kunstwerke in Berlin gerät
die Situation nun außer Kontrolle
am Montagmorgen in Berlin geriet die
klimakleber Situation außer Kontrolle im
Berufsverkehr kommen rettungskräfte der
Feuerwehr verspätet zu einem Unfall eine
Fahrradfahrerin die von einem
Betonmischer erfasst wird schwebt in
Lebensgefahr klar ist man muss eine
klare Kausalität herstellen ja wäre
nicht auch ein anderer Weg mutig gewesen
aber heute so ein bisschen der
Präzedenzfall von dem was wir schon seit
Wochen erzählen ja diejenigen die sich
auf die Straße kleben sagen immer sie
schaffen aber Raum das Rettungswagen
durchkommen also ich glaube wenn
jemanden Staub verursacht der mehrere
Kilometer geht dann sehe ich nicht ob da
hinten noch irgendwo ein RTW feststeckt
oder nicht und es ist schon so dass
jetzt ja sicherlich auch Strafanzeigen
geschrieben werden wegen Nötigung etc
aber eben auch hier vielleicht andere
Sachen im Bereich stehen wenn da
wirklich auch eine Kausalität
herstellbar ist diese Kausalität stellen
die Extremisten sogar selbst her melden
sich nach dem Unfall zu Wort und
schreiben die letzte Generation kann
nicht ausschließen dass die Verspätung
des Rüstwagens auf einen durch uns
verursachten Stau zurückzuführen ist
auch Kanzler Olaf Scholz findet das
besorgniserregend und deshalb kann mein
Appell auch nur sein dass man bei all
den Entscheidungen die man trifft für
politische Kundgebung Meinungsbildung
immer bedenkt dass es nicht zur
Gefährdung anderer beiträgt und wenn das
hier der Fall ist ist das sehr
bedauerlich und sehr bedrückend und
genau deswegen werden die Stimmen nach
härteren Maßnahmen immer lauter ja man
kann auch jemanden 48 Stunden einfach
mal mit ins Gewahrsam nehmen weil man
davon ausgeht dass er wieder eine
Straftat begeht und das ist zum Beispiel
in Bayern nach der Besetzung der BMW
zentrale dort passiert da wurden 15
Personen einfach mal für zwei Wochen
erstmal ein Gewahrsam genommen ja weil
man eben weitere Straftaten verhindern
möchte das ist schon nicht verwunderlich
dass die Protestaktionen immer in Berlin
stattfinden zudem haben wir auch jetzt
nicht unbedingt so den großen
politischen Gegenwind gegen die giriller
Aktion mancher kann Autofahrer verstehen
die kurzerhand selbst Hand anlegen wie
hier ebenfalls in Berlin doch zu
empfehlen ist diese Taktik leider nicht
klar ist auch dass es einzelne
Institutionen wie zum Beispiel
Handwerksbetrieben oder so die dann in
zeitliche ver kommen dass auch den
durchaus zusteht dann zivilrechtlich
gegen die
klimaprotestierenden vorzugehen ja wenn
sie da nur direkte Maßnahmen haben dass
ich zum Beispiel im Auftrag nicht
wahrnehmen konnte weil ich zwei Stunden
im Stau stand der durch jemanden
verursacht wurde dann kann ich da
natürlich gegen vorgehen dass immer der
bessere Weg als sie Gewalt anzuwenden
weil das ist kein Mittel weil da macht
man sich mitunter auch strafbar wenn der
körperverletzten bewegt auch Saurier
sind vor den klimakaoten nicht sicher
warnwestenökos Pappen sich am Wochenende
an ein 66 Millionen Jahre altes
tinoskelett besonders perfide eine
Mutter zieht ihr eigenes Kind mit in die
Aktion ein Kind das sich nicht wehren
kann ebenfalls noch keine eigene Meinung
zu diesem Thema entwickelt hat wir haben
eine Meinung zu klimaklebern leimluschen
und Uhu Ultras sobald das Leben anderer
Menschen gefährdet wird sagen wir runter
von der Straße aber dalli
[Musik]